what's Michaela's most annoying quality
and vice versa M okay there's nothing
annoying about
[Music]
me what makes Jordan both great husbands
and how can I emulate that myself for my
wife so what do you like about Dad if I
tell him what I want he listens and he
doesn't often forget if I don't share
what I need he won't know and we won't
grow closer I can talk to him and he
doesn't get offended I'm like hey this
is really bothering ing me like this
thing you do is really annoying so I
don't have to monitor what I say which
is so freeing you know you're get
pregnant you have hormones and I was way
more irritable and just like didn't have
as much positive emotion and wasn't that
interested in Jordan which was like that
was kind of rough how do I prepare for
marriage to be the best wife I can
be okay how do you prepare how do you
prepare Mom hi welcome to my new podcast
setup
congratulations thank you yeah it's it's
very cool and it's spacious I like it I
like it too good put something right
there okay so it looks a little less
empty in the middle yeah so I took a
bunch of questions from Instagram that
people asked so I think it would be fun
if we just run through some questions
sure have a nice easy podcast okay okay
are you ready think it's easy do you
depends on the questions depends on the
questions that's true does okay we could
start with this
you start with dating advice a couple of
people asked about dating advice do you
have dating advice for people do I have
dating advice H I could start I haven't
well I I have dating but I date with my
husband it's not new dates but if this
were new dates that's what I was
thinking someone that you've just met
probably someone that you've just met
yeah I think so so I would say that um
do a lot of
listening and that that's good advice
for no matter what you're doing but you
want to know who this person is and meet
with them with other people so you can
see how they interact with other people
how you can so you can see how they
react with people in a restaurant who
are Ser who are serving you so you know
what their relationship is to
people um who are who might they might
be paying for their Ser you might be
paying for their services how do they
treat those people you know and you want
to know that and you want you want to
know if you're going
out to to any any place social
what the relationship is between this
person yourself and all the people
around you and that'll teach you a lot
about who they are because everybody is
pretty much who they are in the spur of
the
moment in public you it's pretty hard to
be someone that you're not I think and
so I think that's a good trial for uh
the first time that you go out with
someone is go somewhere public and pay
attention just pay attention you know um
they'll be if they're smart they'll be
they'll be watching you too and so be on
your best behavior and try to be of
service to yourself and to the other
person like keep those things in mind
what do you think about so when I met
Jordan uh and he asked me if he wanted
to marry me I immediately told him
everything that I thought might scare
him away because I was like we didn't
know each other for very long it was
really fast it was like two weeks after
meeting and he was like I want to marry
you and I said you have no idea what
you're getting into hey if you haven't
checked out my anti- hangover pill check
it out at Fuller health.com it's helps
save your brain from from the negative
impact of alcohol and even if you don't
drink often I do not drink often at all
especially now that I'm breastfeeding I
haven't yet actually but one day anyway
if you don't drink often it should be
something that's part of your Wellness
routine anyway that you just have on
your shelf it reduces symptoms of nausea
anxiety shakiness and it even helps a
bit with sleep deprivation because it
works on Gaba as well as helps break
down a cahide which is what poisons you
when you drink we have a 30-day
moneyback guarantee and if you do like
this product please leave a review I
love reading the reviews at Fuller
health.com code mp15 for 15% off linked
in the comments or description enjoy the
rest of this episode with my mom and
then told him like five scary things
which were pretty scary and it was we'll
see if I actually want to say them all
on the podcast but there was um you know
I'm divorced I have a
kid um I work extremely closely with my
family so I'm in like almost constant
communication with my parents um I need
someone that'll help me we were already
working together so but but a little bit
not a lot was like I I would ideally I
have someone that can help me with all
these projects that I'm starting because
they're definitely too much for me and I
work all the time so like my ideal day
other than hanging out with kids is
really working a lot
um and there's an age difference I'm
older than him so I told him all so that
was like six things and I told him that
right away and he was like that's all
fine and I was like well I don't know if
it's fine I think you might be young and
naive we'll see um but it's been working
out splendidly but what do you think I I
think my advice truth and like
real honesty because maybe the scary
parts of you aren't as scary as you
think they are right
hopefully well hopefully you've learned
from your experiences so which makes you
more wise than you may have been yeah if
like these are all the things that
happened these are the things I've
learned yeah yeah that's a good point
yeah and I think if you end up scaring
somebody Away by telling them who you
are then they weren't meant to be anyway
they're going to it's going to come up
anyway so you might as well try scaring
them away at the beginning saves a lot
of
time that was dating advice
K this was kind of interesting it's how
are you different and how are you
similar in parenting Styles well I
wasn't around to witness your parenting
style but you're like kind of around to
witness my parenting style
mhm um let's see I stayed home with my
kids so I spent a lot of time with my
kids and
uh I I didn't put up with a lot of
misbehavior neither do
you uh um I like to set I like to have a
routine so a nightly
routine dinners lunches breakfast all of
that was routine in our house and we ate
together every
meal um so that was part of my parenting
style was to set up
routines and I think that the routines
for little kids they start to become
aware of
what they can offer for those routines
so I can remember when we were in Boston
and Julian was pretty teeny tiny he was
he could walk you know he could he was
he was stable on his feet and Jordan was
getting him to put the knives and forks
on the table and he couldn't quite reach
the table but he could get them up there
that's cute and yeah and that was it was
good so we tried to uh include you guys
in the running of the house from as
early age as you could Master you know
to to clean your to clean up your toys
and you know when you teach a little kid
to clean up their toys uh you have to
make
it small enough that they can be
successful so it's not just clean up
your room it's do you see this toy right
here does this toy belong somewhere in
the room where does it belong on the
Shelf can do you think you could put it
on the Shelf like and and it's so it's
slow it's slow and it's one thing after
the next but if you do that if you take
the time for that eventually they are
very proud of themselves because they
know how to do it on their own and
that's how you build uh
Independence uh and that's also how you
build uh
trust because I think they can see that
every day there's something that's
similar every day so then they can
predict their lives and that's good for
them keeps them
calm did you this is my question um when
we started doing chores did we get paid
to do things like clean our room I've
been having a discussion with Jordan
because I remember like Sunday was
chores day and we had this list of
chores and every I don't know six months
maybe we used to sort out like okay
who's going to do this room and who's
going to do that room like who's in
charge of what room and so we'd have a
list of things we were supposed to do on
Sundays you remember this right well we
went we we met on Sundays we met on
Sundays about 4 in the afternoon when
you guys still wanted to be playing
outside with your friends yep right in
the middle of the play time right in the
middle of playtime um but we met every
Sunday at that time and we we would say
okay there's say five jobs in the house
that have to be done every week who
wants to choose you choose which job do
you want so if you choose you're going
to put out the garbage then and that's
your job for the week if you choose
you're going to um you know make beds if
you choose you're going to help prepare
a dinner or are you going to wash the
dishes and so but every Sunday you got
to choose so it was oh we did that every
Sunday because sometimes you do
something you didn't really want to do
and you only had to do it for a week you
weren't locked in for six months that's
better um so I've been talking to Jordan
about implementing chores um and
was trying to kind of mimic I don't
think we're going to do the Sunday sit
down I remember that was in the middle
of playtime but uh but Jordan was like I
never got paid to do things like keep my
room clean because it's my room so it's
my responsibility to keep clean so I
shouldn't be paid for it we didn't pay
you I thought we had we got like
$2 and it was just we had to complete
all our chores I thought it was like
bundled in that could be but I wasn't
part of that Dad was part of the
monetary compensation yeah yeah yeah
that's funny okay next $2 wasn't very
much even back then you can only get so
many sour keys for
$2 that's good that's what I remember
that's good only only a few sour Keys
yeah okay how has our relationship
changed with each other over the years
especially since
Michaela had kids do you think me having
kids has been what's changed our
relationship or just time
oh well I think having kids changes the
relationship between a mother and a
daughter well you understand your mom a
lot more once you go through it like oh
wow okay this is what she went through
that's a lot yeah and there's no way you
can understand that without having kids
I know not at all no it's hard to
believe it's hard to believe it's as um
all all consuming as it is because at
the beginning it's all consuming and how
you you just have no idea how cons
consuming it is cuz you've never done
anything like that where you're at the
beck and call of a of someone who needs
you and you have no choice in the matter
that's it's really something I had this
uh well you know how much I like working
and Building Things and creating and
so and I completely I had Scarlet she's
six so that was almost wow so that was
six years ago and like that's a very
long time and I feel like when
the hormones wear off from the very
beginning when they're really little you
kind of forget again so I forgot so I
had this idea during pregnancy that I
was like I'm not going to take any mat
leave and I didn't end up taking any mat
leave before I had George because he
came 36 weeks so I actually didn't end
up taking any time but at 30 when you
guys came to stay when I was around 32
weeks my body kind of was like good luck
doing everything you were doing cuz is
like no you need to rest more and there
wasn't much I could do to push through
that but then I completely
forgot how crazy you Fe not crazy like
insane exactly but like how
all-encompassing a baby is once you have
a baby cu I was like I can schedule
thing and it's early he's going to be
three weeks right he's it's early but
like you it's like you don't have much
of a choice it's like oh I have an idea
of I'm going to be able to do all these
things and I forgot with the sleep
deprivation and nursing every you nurse
for like an hour every three or four
hours right so that's fulltime that's
full-time work day yeah that's the day
it's like of a two-hour period where I
can do a podcast let's see if I can
handle this today
but it's crazy what um it's crazy what
moms go through yeah and that time that
you spend with your child when you're
you're nursing where you can look at
each other that is that
is Magic that's
magic it's good for him it's good for
the M that creates that attachment
that's the first thing that creat stop
attachment issues yeah mhm yeah crazy
and then when the kid gets a little bit
older he'll start to really pay
attention to your reactions to his
emotion
to see if he's got his emotions if he's
expressing emotions properly oh I
watched this and I knew this already
because because of scarlet and having a
kid but I watched this video on it was
on Instagram or something and it showed
what happens if you overreact to a kid
falling over so if a kid falls over
there's this like Split Second where
they look at you to see how they're
going to react and if you react in a
neurotic way like ah are you like oh my
gosh that must have hurt they'll scream
M and like who knows what they're
feeling if they see pain in your face
right and then if you go oh that was
kind of funny like you're okay like get
yourself up sometimes they'll laugh
instead of scream and so it's important
to be stable and like a calm presence
and not try
and make your kids neurotic yeah and for
them to come for a hug when they need a
hug you know when you were only about
you were 22 months old when Julian was
born
and we taught you to before he was born
to come for a hug whenever you needed
one and we told you that you know I was
going to be really busy yeah once the
baby was born and so I needed you to
come to me and tell you tell me what you
needed and you did you like we practiced
it before he was born and then if Jordan
and I if he would come home from work
and give me a hug you'd stand you'd get
in between us oh Scarlett does that yeah
and that's very good that's cool yeah
that's very good that's a good idea yeah
I talked to Scarlet about it too because
I was like in bed for two weeks yeah
after having a baby
uh and I told her that at the beginning
the baby takes a lot of time because I'm
really tired and he's really tired and
nursing is a
lot so she has to come for attention
yeah yeah that's good that is
good
okay what makes Jordan both m mhm it's
not actually convenient that we're both
married to somebody named Jordan but
it's convenient for this question to ask
her what makes Jordan both great
husbands and how can I emulate that
myself for my wife so what do you like
about
Dad um he's very devoted to me he is
yeah very he's very he's very in love
with you yeah he is nice y he he uh if I
tell him what I want he listens and he
pays attention
and he doesn't often forget so sharing
ex sharing truthfully what I need with
him is really important because then he
gets to know me better and without if I
don't share what I need he won't know
and we won't grow closer and so we're
very close because I try to be you know
the whole the whole thing when we were
first married it was tell the truth that
was the rule tell the truth and so we
practiced that for 35 years what's an
example of something that you
need I need him to buy me clothing that
I like and when he first bought me
clothing it wasn't anything I liked but
I didn't say never buy me clothing again
you know I said this isn't your Forte
just give up yeah that's right I so I
had to educate him on what was what was
a successful purchase and what was a not
successful purchase and and he paid
attention and he he got better at it so
that was good because it gave him
pleasure to be able to buy me
something that I
wanted do you
remember uh the Christmas it must have
been 2015 we had a Christmas and dad got
me this little leather bat purse and
this is when I was in university and I
had taken out a loan and I didn't have
very much money and it was this bat
person it was this big and it was a bat
and it had the silver chain and I was
like okay I can't even fit a phone in
this I can barely put like coins in here
it's like leather and he's all happy
about this leather bat purse and then he
got
you it was a skeleton bracelet holding
on to your arm it was it a sket yeah
right up to the wrist it was horrifying
it was hor we opened it and I don't
think any of us could be like
fake the positive emotion and dad was so
excited about this skeleton hand
skeleton bracelet and this little bat
purse he was like Merry
Christmas I think he thought well I
don't know he must have missed Halloween
I don't know I don't know was pretty
funny yeah yeah but it but it's
funny what else so what else what else
because there's more
you know he is uh a
[Music]
very he's a man who's he's a deep
thinker right he's definitely a deep
thinker but just because he's a deep
thinker doesn't mean he knows
everything that that's not what that
means it means he's thought very deeply
about the things that he's thought
deeply
about but the problem with that often is
that there's other things that he is not
so aware of and so helping him become
aware of these things that he's missed
helps our relationship too and I was
very different than him he was uh very
he was a an academic he was a um an
intellectual and I
was spiritual and
physical and so we brought different we
brought different values to the
relationship and so I think those things
that we shared what we treasured in our
lives with each other and we became
closer and closer well it's kind of
amazing watching you guys
because like my Jordan and I we similar
I would say would you say like there
there's differences but we're pretty
similar personality wise um and you guys
aren't no like and it's pretty
marked so
it's interesting
that you guys work so well together
being so different well you know we do
share some things we're both open so
we're both creative and so we share that
openness we share that
creativity um he's you know and I'm
extroverted he's just crazy extroverted
I used to think I used to think that you
weren't extroverted because of how
extroverted dad is and I was like oh no
you have your own podcast you're opening
his shows and you're you talk too when
like you go out to parties and things
you're buzzing around but
he's like he's on another level of
extroverted yeah so I was like oh Mom's
introverted and then I met some actual
introverts I was like oh that's not it
yeah so yeah so I I'm kind of my
personality is kind of middle of the
road compared to his you're both
conscientious too we're both more
orderly we both cons yeah so it's really
just
the
and although he's quite agreeable and
I'm more disagreeable uh in terms of
being a man and a woman our
personalities are probably fairly close
that
way I'm more disagreeable than him but
not very much more a little bit more
it's noticeable because I'm more blunt
he's more polite and that can cause
trouble that can definitely cause
trouble I can say something blunt and
it'll embarrass him and he'll accept
ccept something that he probably
wouldn't have accepted if he wasn't
embarrassed so I have to be really
careful that I
don't say
something to to make him
uncomfortable do you so when you say
those things cuz I remember being made
uncomfortable by things you would say as
a teenager too I think less so now yeah
actually I don't think at all anymore
which is funny I don't I don't think I
you said something that made me feel
uncomfortable in years years I was like
nah she's probably right like but as a
teenager for sure maybe that's partly
cuz I wasn't well um well it wasn't just
that it was partly me too I think that
uh my experience when I was
ill and uh my humility that I gained
from that experience of being so sick
has been very good for me and my
relationships with other
people hm okay that's definitely
possible I think so well I think we get
along splendidly now yeah we do we've
had a really good time we've been here
together off and on for a number of
weeks now right so that's pretty good
Mon and I was I before I got here I I
wasn't sure like I wonder how we're
going to get along but it's been just
fun yeah yeah you guys came to stay when
I was 32 weeks and that was kind of the
time when I was like oh I'm really tired
um yeah I wasn't that worried wored
about it I know Dad called me and we're
like is this going to be okay we're all
in the same house but um it's been
totally fine well and you guys are
pretty good at and Jordan Fuller also is
pretty good at telling us what he's
thinking he's blunt he's blun but he's
blun like I'm blunt he very I know he um
Dad bought this container for our sink
cuz we have this big sink in the kitchen
and if you wash dishes in it like food
will get stuck in the corner and then
you have to like rinse out the corners
so Dad bought a bucket for the sink to
wash dishes
in and Jordan my Jordan had a issue with
this bucket in the sink we're not having
a bucket in the sink or houses filling
up with was like I just married a
version of my mother but but then a
couple days ago they're both in the
kitchen and dad goes we figured out how
to organize ourselves with a bucket I
can use the bucket and then it'll just
go in this cupboard and my Jordan was
like yeah we can both get behind that
but I was like this bucket was a big
deal three weeks ago this sink bucket I
was like I don't care I'm about to have
a baby I don't care about the bucket in
the sink
Jordan funny yeah yeah it's been good
though it's been fun it's been nice
having you here thank you it's been good
to be
here um and then I guess I could answer
that get a bit what what makes my Jordan
a good husband yep
H well he really likes me too which is
really
nice um it's
important yeah it's really important to
like each other that sounds silly but
like that's very important they should
basically be your best friend yeah
otherwise how are you going to live with
somebody for a long period of time who's
not your best
friend and so I don't know he's my best
friend I guess that's what makes him a
great
husband and He does care about things
sometimes I have to hammer it in a
little bit he's also a challenge right
Jordan's a my Jordan's a challenge you
know what's great I know what's great I
know what's great I can talk to him and
he doesn't get offended when I talk to
him so I'm like hey this is really
bothering me this is like this thing you
do is really
annoying and he either argues with me
for a while mhm
and then we'll come to some consensus
about it but he doesn't get offended by
it so I don't have to monitor what I say
which is so freeing because if you talk
to someone and you can pick up that
they're kind of
like oh like they get offended then you
can't communicate with them because
they're like okay this thing is bugging
me how do I bring it up to this person
without hurting their
feelings and that's so exhausting to
think in the back of your mind all the
time impossible to always be able to do
that and it means that you just lie how
do I say this in a way that doesn't hurt
their feelings is like you don't have to
be rude to people you don't have to be
like you said you don't have to be as
blunt as you can possibly be towards
somebody you can you can think about the
way you say things to bring them up in
an appropriate way but having to monitor
everything you say all the time is just
it just makes you either not say things
or lie so I'd say that's the best thing
about him is I can talk to him without
him getting offended so any little
problem we have and we'll have little
problems throughout the day there aren't
really problems because I can just say
them and
then sometimes it's a problem with me
right and sometimes when I talk to them
I'll go okay I'm not feeling good that's
obviously what's happening is like I'm
anxious and then so maybe it's a problem
with me but that's probably my favorite
thing about him other than the fact we
get along really well is I can just talk
to him without him being offended well
it's very helpful for both of you or
both of us to be self-reflective so that
we can tell what our moods are like and
help our partners understand where we're
coming from because you you don't want
to impose yourself on someone else
because you're nervous about something
or afraid of something like angry or
resentful yeah so so tell tell your
partner how you're
if you're if there's something that is
motivating you that you're not
comfortable with it share share that and
talk it through until you have a until
you have until the dance of your
relationship reemerges again then you
know you've talked enough because
otherwise if it's still there you
haven't negotiated enough and you have
to you have to keep at it you know you
have to bring that to a resolution so
that it is no longer there's no longer
any sharp edges to it
yeah yeah mhm then the fun emerges again
hey guys check out these soaps this is
what I use these are what I have at my
house I'm allergic to soap generally as
is my mom took after my mom in a lot of
ways that way uh like that movie theater
soap that's pink and liquid literally
makes my hands turn bright red anyway I
use Stone and spear soap they carry
moisturizer soap face cream shampoos
deodorants lip balms toothpaste Etc
they're all made from all natural
ingredients like Tallow and Tallow soap
does not bother me look at this hippie
soap anyway I'm forced into reducing
toxins from my life because of
autoimmune responses and it's really
something everyone should do before they
have autoimmune problems or chronic
illness given we're exposed to an insane
number of chemicals in our environment
beef Tallow which is rich in Omega-3s in
vitamins a d e K2 B12 12 choline is the
perfect substance to cleanse nourish and
moisturize our skin and it's what was
used in soap before soap manufacturers
got a hold of soap big soap their
moisturizer is also bomb and works
insanely well for dry skin if you put it
on your legs it makes your legs like
shine in a very nice way check them out
at Stone andp tall.com use code MP for
10% off my favorite products are these
they have this charcoal soap this soap
and their moisturizers they're linked in
the comments or the description enjoy
the rest of this episode it's wild too
with all the like so pregnancy hormones
I was definitely you know you get
pregnant you have hormones so our
relationship changed during that and I
was way more irritable and just like
didn't have as much positive emotion
just didn't feel as good and wasn't that
interested in Jordan which was like that
was kind of rough for cuz it's 8 months
me being like I don't really want to be
touched
like kind of nauseous I'm just just like
maybe I should go live in a cave for the
next 8 months and reemerged with a
baby um but we seem to have negotiated
that pretty well but that changes so
even if you the nice thing about
communicating with somebody else
throughout all these things is
especially if you have kids is like your
relationship changes goes up and down
but if you just can communicate then you
can come out on the other side
but being able to talk to somebody
without them taking off is that's really
important for that's really important
for me apparently and I think also if
you in terms of romance in a
relationship and keeping the romance
alive if you don't have this
communication with each other if you
don't keep keep up with the little
niggly things that bother you if you
don't discuss those things then if you
try to have a date uh yeah those will be
in your way and so you have to to have
communication ongoing communication so
that when you decide one night that you
want to have a date it's
possible you're not annoyed about the
last 30 things you guys didn't talk
about that's right so don't let it get
away on yourself but keep up keep up if
there's something and you know what so
my dad passed away my dad died two weeks
ago yeah almost three yeah so on the
11th of December actually the day that
George was born which was awesome CU he
brought Joy way to us that's the way it
should be HH that's the way it should be
that was pretty yeah weird it was
perfect it was perfect my dad he left
and and he left and George came it was
something mystical about that it was
really something it was crazy actually
you guys called me you facetimed me
right when my water broke yeah right is
that right it it had broken maybe 20
minutes before wow wow yeah and then you
called was like wo wow lot going on
today yeah lot going on
today yeah I can't remember what I was
going to say now but anyway well that's
okay let's keep going okay do we have
any shared quirky Behavior oh
probably share I don't know if we share
any
um what do you what do how do you define
quirky Behavior I don't know let me
think is there anything that I do that
reminds me of you
well I think the main similarity that we
share
is now that I'm older
is I'm probably pretty fast to pick up
on people or judge people if you want to
call it that it's judging people but
it's also I think being intuitive and I
I think I get that from you not dad
because mom used to I used to bring
friends home this is something that just
bothered me so much as a teenager I used
to bring friends home and sometimes I'd
bring a friend home and you'd kind of be
cold and you just be like nah not that
person and I was like Mom why are you so
mean to I don't know if it was obvious
to anybody other than like your family
but I was like why are you like kind of
cold and mean to this person what did
they do they don't deserve that and then
inevitably each time that person would
be just some like horrible person it was
full trouble I had this is good I so
when I moved out I went to Concordia in
Montreal and I moved into this apartment
and the apartment had five people living
in including me and one of the guys
living in it who was about three or four
years older than me was insane um and
he'd had like he was just he was he had
a lot of money I don't think he'd had
any attention as a kid and he was so
there were reasons that led him into
being the the person he was but the
person he was was not a great person and
he was old enough that like you have to
get yourself together you can't just
blame your childhood for the your
personality anymore but we went into
that apartment and he was crazy as soon
as I got there so he came out and he's
like did you use my towel I was like I
literally just moved my stuff and I
don't even know who you are like did you
use my towel it's like I didn't use your
towel and Mom just goes and hides in my
room and and my dad and we go out for
dinner afterwards and my dad's like well
he might just he's given all these
reasons why this guy might be fine and
Mom's just like oh no he's he's nuts
he's nuts and wow was he nuts anyway I
ended up moving out of that that condo
in four months because we fought so much
he lied it was that was the first time I
came across somebody who lied all the
time he convinced me this is actually
crazy he convinced me that he was
friends with the people who owned the
condo building and he'd chosen us all As
roommates M and we were just there
because he' looked at our cuz you needed
an application to get in and on my
application I I had like stays up late
goes out like because you write all that
down and they theoretically put you
together with other people like you
which they don't do it was just to make
you feel good about filling out a form
but um he came in one day was like you
lied about your form and I was like I
didn't lie on my form but I had thought
I thought for like 3 months that he'd
chosen us as roommates because he was
always hanging downstairs with the
people at the front desk and
things wow there like a lot of things
went on in that apartment but then you
went and you lived with two of the girls
that lived in that you took I moved
apartments no I didn't take anyone I I
moved out oh you know and you know part
of the reason I moved out is cuz on my
birthday he came in and told me all the
roommates had signed to get me to move
out because we were really fighting like
he had he had some OCD Tendencies and I
used to move things around in the condo
to to bother him but it was because I'd
put dishes away and he'd tell me I put
the cups in wrong and I was like driving
me crazy and anyway he told me all the
roommates had signed this piece of paper
and got me like to move out and so I
moved cuz I didn't like him anyway and
then all the roommates were like why'
you move I was like well you know there
was this piece of paper and you guys
asked me to move out was like there was
no piece of paper anyway that was good
luck actually cuz you left thank
goodness I left that moved with a bunch
of girls and they were equally insane
like me and it was it was a good time
yes you had much better time the next
semester but but you uh you figured him
out in about two seconds yeah just left
I just looked at him and thought
oh uh
oh how do I prepare for marriage to be
the best wife I can
be this is a question for
you oh okay how do you prepare how do
you prepare well you think
about
who if you've had any good hopefully
you've had a good uh
male in your life a good man in your
life maybe it's your father but maybe
it's your uncle maybe it was a teacher
maybe it was a priest I mean I don't
know who who the good example of a man
is someone who you can trust and someone
who you could look up to and think about
who that is someone that someone you
admire and that could be your
husband like really really deeply think
about the attributes that that person
had that makes you admire
them that's your husband write those
things
down and
then pray on that say this is this is
who this is who I'm looking for this is
my Prince Charming that's that's who I'm
looking for and you're way more likely
you're way more likely to meet someone
then who's like that because your eyes
are open and you have a focus and you
have a goal in mind and so that's really
helpful because you're not as George
says you're not going to hit a goal if
you don't aim for it I like that write
down what you want write down what you
want and pray on it yeah that seems
that's sounds like Sound Advice
I think my advice would
be practice for a female in particular
like how to be a good wife practice not
doing things you don't want to
do and and setting up proper boundaries
so that when you get into a relationship
you'll be able to tell the truth and I
think I struggled with that until I was
about
27 and I think some people struggle for
a lot longer but I think some people
figure it out a lot earlier and I would
just say try to have the proper
boundaries so don't say yes to anything
you don't want to do yeah because it's
kind of a lie well that's a sin that's a
sin of of sorts I think saying yes to
things that make that you don't want to
do yeah even if you think it's better or
wanting something and then not
insisting that's another kind of Sin Sin
of
omission not doing what you not doing
what what you need to do is a sin too
it's a sin for your own soul you know I
mean it hurts you yeah it hurts you so
you have to be careful of those things
yes those are important things yeah and
I think you can work I think you can do
a lot of work on yourself before you
find someone to just turn yourself into
somebody people want to be married to or
that ideally your your future spouse
will fall in love with but I think it's
really important especially for women
because I don't I know if it's how our
personality is just being female and
more more
compassionate um generally speaking or
if it's from how we're brought up as
women like so I think some of it might
be societal which is just like if you're
a girl you should be doing more for
other people I think that that might be
societal in in some way um but it's also
personality wise you want to do more for
more people um you might do more more
for more people and leave yourself
out and I don't know if I don't know if
more women do that men maybe I I'm not
sure oh there's definitely men that do
that as well there's men that do that as
well but you have to realize that who
you
are
uh who you are today is not who you're
going to be tomorrow and definitely not
who you're going to be in 10 years and
you have to do what you need to do for
that person to prosper too and
actually you can't really help other
people unless you're helping yourself to
become a better person so you have you
you really I think you do have to really
focus on your own needs what you need
not what you want particularly but what
you need what what uh what grips you you
know what brings meaning to your life
you have you have to do those things and
if you do those things it'll inspire you
to be uh to to to share what you know
and to help other people find their way
and you know so but it's really
important cuz you know when so when my
dad died a couple weeks ago I learned
something um
I couple of days after I got
here uh he had only been dead for a
couple of days when I came because we
are going to have a celebration of life
this summer and we cremated them and we
went there and that was good but then we
left and my husband didn't come back
with me so I was alone here and uh I was
alone for about 5 days and then I talked
I'm taking Catholic lessons so I talked
to my priest and I admitted that I was
feeling resentful because my husband
didn't come home with me and I was
grieving and I was suffering and he said
did you pray on it and I thought yeah I
prayed on it and then I thought well did
I actually like did I really pray on it
and I thought oh my goodness I was
looking to have my
grief relieved from my husband or even
from my daughter or even from my
granddaughter from people when I needed
to ask God to come to me and help me
with that and once and it just came to
me that that was actually right and that
night that night I received my Dad's
obituary
and I thought oh it's a beautiful
obituary it just says exactly who he was
in the best best light possible and
Jordan my Jordan wrote it and my brother
Dale oh did he write it he wrote it
right in the funeral home he just
started to write it and then my brother
edited it and we you know sent it to
everyone who wanted to add something and
you know got it done but my Jordan wrote
it and you know my husband has known my
dad since Jord was 7even years old he's
known my dad so he did really know him
and he did really like him and so he's
he wrote a beautiful obituary and I
wanted to share it with people I had
asked God to come to me and and help me
with my grief and then I just felt like
sharing my love for my father with
everyone and I shared it with like 36
people on Messenger anyone who might
know him I sent it to him my friends
Jordan's friends my cousins like people
I high school friends like anybody who
might have known them I sent it to them
and then I started getting all these
responses and these little stories about
him and I started to cry and I cried
quite a bit that night but it was what I
needed it was what I needed but I
couldn't reach out with this love that I
felt for my dad until I had asked it
until I had asked for God to come and
help me with my grief because I was I
was uh I was lonely but of course I'm
not alone because I have this constant
love from the Lord above and I can ask
for that whenever I want I just am not
that used to it so I hadn't asked
properly but when I did ask properly I
felt so full that I just wanted to share
love everywhere and I thought wow that's
wonderful and
remarkable so I'm definitely bad at that
how
but I
guess if you go through something
traumatic or if you're having a hard
time I mean is it unreasonable to have
people around you to support you oh no I
don't think it's unreasonable but it's
really hard you can't get something from
them they they aren't going to give you
you have to give to them so when I was
sick with cancer and I came home to tell
Julian that I was going to die in 10
months I had accepted it in the doctor's
office as if it was true and I came home
to tell him that and I saw this deep
love like maternal love
sorry sorry but when I saw that I I was
filled up with with love I realized that
I was worthwhile saving because I was
his mother and so and I wanted to stay
around to be his mother right and
when I was just thinking about me
whether I was going to live or die I was
thinking about myself just as
myself not about who I'm attached to and
who's attached to me which is the
important part of the whole of the whole
story is Who Am I who do I have
relationships with all those people yes
all those people are really really
important even all those people I
messaged on messenger are really
important people but I can't reach out
to them until I'm filled up with love
that I have asked
for from God and I didn't know that but
I certainly know it repeatedly and so I
learned it that day with that cancer
diagnosis and told Julian that only God
knows when I'm going to live or die
first of all I realized that and that I
would accept whatever treatment came my
way way because I wanted to stay alive
as long as possible to be with him and
serve him in whatever way I could and
Jordan and you and like whoever else but
he was there at that at that moment and
now my dad has died and I was grieving
and not unsure of how to deal with it
but once I realized too that I realized
oh my goodness I need to ask
directly from above come to me I need
you I'm
suffering and then I was full of love
like just like that just like that how
can that
be that's wild you know that's wild but
it's happened twice now in my
life Wow and I think if I practice it it
can happen who knows how much wow yeah
it's a practice wow that's cool yeah
it's a practice all all the things that
you take through your life like being
married this you know uh when you come
home at night how you want to be treated
when you come in the door you want that
every day you come home that's a
practice you know uh at at the dinner
table how you interact with each other
at the dinner table that happens every
night you want that to be a practice and
you want to perfect it and make it
beautiful and loving and then you can
have that in all parts of your life and
it's uh it's a blast
to do that it makes your life into an
adventurous a loving adventure and wow
what else do you need really than that
so yeah it's pretty
cool that is pretty cool it's pretty
cool that was nice good yeah I have to
remember that yeah remember that if you
can call me if you're suffering and I'll
say you know did you take that in prayer
okay maybe I'll do that that's that's
that's that's be good stepping stone yes
Jordan sometimes will be fighting about
something and he'll be like maybe you
should pray like I don't want to pray
right now it's like uh yeah maybe I do
but but not from not from you telling me
yeah I can call you that should work
yeah you
could okay um how did you feel being a
stay at home mom how did I feel I had no
cell phone right it was before cell
phones it was
before the internet was just getting
going so there was really no
communication except for what I would
there was a telephone and there was
going outside and finding people so so I
it was it was lonely for sure but
um I had some things I like to do you
know I was an
artist and uh I drew you when you were
just teen
right just when you could sit up I drew
pictures of you so and I really like
that so I think you have to maintain
those interests that you have uh some
people you know it's you know back to
work I don't recommend that if you don't
have to go back to work I wouldn't go
back to work because your baby needs you
for uh and you need to nurse if you can
and you need the baby and you need the
baby yes you're finding that right
sometimes oh yeah it's crazy mhm you
need the baby and the baby needs you and
so don't go back to work but engage
in and and give people and and um bring
people over and you know spend time with
people bring people over uh go for walks
if you can go for your walks and it's so
funny when I remember I lived in a part
of Montreal that was um let's see it was
Italian Portuguese it was Portuguese
and uh we used to go out for breakfast
in the morning it was $3.25 for bacon
and eggs it was nothing you know and
Jordan and I used to go out for
breakfast all the time and when you were
born we took you out to breakfast with
us because a little baby you can pretty
much take them anywhere and I remember
this man he was Frenchman with black
curly hair and Burly guy he was looked
like a lumberjack from Quebec Frenchman
and he turned around he was in the next
uh seat he turned around and the smile
on his
face and he was just like guccii GUI
guci all of a sudden he turned into a
father you know and uh if I hadn't had a
baby well he wouldn't have turned around
or had anything to do with us and so I
noticed that I could walk around the
neighborhood now and crossing the street
people would stop and say hello or or
congratulate us and and it was so
different all of a sudden this place
that had really been pretty Anonymous I
was pretty Anonymous nobody even really
my upstairs neighbor didn't even know I
was pregnant even though I had a baby in
January I had probably lots of big
clothes on and he didn't notice but once
the baby was there then everybody
noticed and everybody said hello and all
of a sudden I was part of the community
in a way that I hadn't been before I was
part of this club of parents that is
Broad and it's not class-based or
anything it's just all the people who
have children and everybody can have
children so it's everyone and in that
way then I wasn't lonely because I had
all of that kind of community around me
and it was
good I think I was
so stressed out with Scarlet that I
couldn't pick up on that M I just didn't
like it I was so anxious it was cool
crazy it was so rough but it's not like
that anymore at all that's good so thank
God for that well once once George gets
a little older and you can go out you'll
see it this time you'll see it yeah yeah
yeah well I remember people coming up
but I remember just being
like people I don't know I don't want to
talk to you just cuz I have a baby yeah
well Dela told me my sister told me when
I had a baby I'd be a member of a new
club and uh it is you're member of
you're now a member of the club of the
family club that you weren't a member
before and you never even saw it existed
but now you're part of it and people
will welcome you in I think it's because
you
understand how like hard it is what what
it is yeah it it's
profound it's a profound change there's
nothing that grows up a girl except for
having a baby that grows a girl into a
woman yeah and it grows a boy into a
father and and that grow it grows you up
and
so it's it's so
profound what's michela's most annoying
quality and vice
versa okay H there's nothing annoying
about
me um I won't be offended I promise
you're kind of you're kind of
blunt I'm I'm afraid you're a bit like
me you're kind of blunt and so in emails
sometimes you can be a little
a little hard to take and I'd say that's
probably the most annoying part was that
just pregnant me though or did that
happen before pregnant me I think that I
think that you have a tendency to be
rather blunt okay I was going to say
your most annoying quality is your
tendency to be rather blunt that's kind
of annoying sometimes yeah and when I
realized that you were blunt I thought
uhoh she's just like
me I didn't want that to be the case but
it is the case funny okay that's funny
though we've both got that and it's both
kind of it's both annoying yeah so it is
annoying right yeah it is annoying it's
not like you're just like me and so it's
fine no actually that's not true that's
funny I think Jordan's made it
worse well I think when you love someone
you can be very blunt with them so you
have to be really careful with the
people you love not to be blunt with
them and I've noticed that when I'm
blunt things that I that aren't supposed
to happen that I don't even want to
happen do happen and when I'm kind and
you know if I have something to say to
reserve it until the right time so that
it comes till God's time so that when it
comes it's not because I decided it
comes it comes because it was the right
time for it to come and then it doesn't
cause any waves that's much better
that's important yeah it's really
important waiting for things to happen
too when you realize oh this thing like
this thing should happen or I want this
thing to happen whether it's at work or
in your relationship yeah but I've
noticed that in terms of work so
building Peterson Academy it's like
there's some parts that have been really
difficult to like oh we're missing a
feature like something's missing here um
but we're not sure how to integrate it
or we're not exactly sure how to make it
fit
um oh like okay so the writing component
for the app we were like we're going to
have all the courses online and we're
going to have testing involved in the
courses but for some courses like
Humanities courses you kind of need an
essay component um and it took a year
and a half of me being like how on Earth
do you incorporate an essay component
into an app where you don't want people
to go off the app like it's kind of
messy so we didn't incorporate it and
then like two days ago we figured out
how to incorporate it in and for people
watching it's going to be op in you
don't you're not forced to write essays
if you watch the courses you can just
watch the courses and learn but if you
want to write essays there's now a way
to write them but it was the same um I
think since probably
since becoming a Christian and I was
like God there's a real there really is
something to God's timing where you can
say I really want this to happen and you
can push on it and push on it and if it
just doesn't work like all the doors are
closed and you can't get through them
you can just wait sometimes and
sometimes I don't know it takes like the
essay component for the app's not that
important of a of an issue in life it
took a year and a half right so these
things take they happen in the time that
they're supposed to happen yeah yeah
it's cool though you just be like well
he'll take care of it at some point
it'll just the only way to notice it is
to pause and not say the thing that is
going to cause conflict and to wait to
like put it aside what the thing that
you want to say maybe it's significant
maybe it's not but maybe it's
significant let's put that aside and
we're just going to file it we're going
to file that and then when it's right to
say it we'll say it and that time may
never come how is that different though
I hate doing that by the way like if I
if there's something wrong I'm like this
needs to be figured out I'm getting this
out of me right now but how is that
different than hiding things well you
are you are acknowledging that you have
something to say but you're filing it so
you're not saying I'm not going to say
that you're saying I'm going to I'm
going to uh give
this to
God and God will help me know when the
right time is and so it's a it's a it's
a it's Faith it's a it's a move of Faith
to put something that you strongly
desire you really but you know that if
you presented it now it would be
trouble okay okay no I've I can think of
some examples then yeah yeah you put to
side and sometimes I'll say whatever
that was in a moment and think oh right
there that thing was and and I've said
it and it wasn't even my plan because
now is the right time and it didn't
cause any trouble and I think huh wow
that's cool okay yeah that makes sense I
can get behind that okay
was there ever a rocky time between you
two and how did you handle it oh yeah
there was lots of Rocky times tons Rocky
times yeah tons of Rocky times but
really you were very sick and I and I
also had my own health troubles too
right when I used to eat gluten oh my
God and when I used to take well I
stopped taking the birth control pill
when Julian was born so you didn't know
me then but when I used to eat gluten oh
my
God it was first of all it was
exhausting because I was falling asleep
all the time but I also had no patience
it made me kind of crazy and so I was
much more reactive than than I am now
now I'm pretty you
know pretty yeah and I was insanely sick
volatile yeah and very but very sick but
sick from and like with the
anti-depressants and just so sick that
yeah we had Rocky times but when I look
back at that like especially during my
teenage years I mostly look back and
think
whoo like I was really
sick that's what I think too yeah okay
yeah that's all that's all I think
really and I
think well it's just it was unfortunate
and it couldn't be dealt with any sooner
than it was dealt with I always I prayed
to my mother you know my mother died in
200 seven how old were you then um you
born 92 92 I had the joints replac in
2009 7 I would have been 15 so when my
mother died I started and I may have
prayed to her before that but CU she was
ill for a couple of years not 15 that
would make me much older than I am I was
not 15 let's just clarify that I don't
have to be any older than I already
am no that that would
have I don't know younger than 15 maybe
so so I started praying for you then
through my mom every
day and I just asked my mom to intercede
you know come and intercede Mom we need
you a
MH and then you got better and I was
like thank you
Mom yeah thank you
Mom what were your first impressions of
my husband I remember oh I remember we
where did we meet in a restaurant like
we were sitting somewhere I think it
might have been a restaurant and he sat
beside me and uh he would he turned to
me he say hi Tammy say hi did I tell you
I love your daughter a and then and he
told me that that night five times
really five times yeah that's so nice a
yeah we were arguing before this podcast
but that's pretty sweet a that's nice
yes I think your first impression was I
was at the cottage with you guys and he
was FaceTiming me and um I introduced
you to him on the phone and you went are
you
gay I did didn't I that was your actual
that was the less sweet first impression
but like to be fair he was pretty nice
look good hair yeah y so I thought well
maybe I got to
ask I think you were just testing him
that was definitely that was definitely
just a test yeah it's just that's what
we mean by like if sense of humor like
yeah yeah what's his reaction going to
be if I just say this don't even know
who this my dad was like right I know
yeah so I've inherited some of that it
was funny though yeah was
funny a that's nice
mhm okay best advice that you gave me
this one's for me mhm
advice I think the thing that I'm most
grateful that I got from you rather than
it wasn't straight up advice like Dad
dollan out advice it it
was watching you probably taught me to
be more intuitive like I always knew you
were intuitive and I didn't understand
what that was and I didn't believe I
didn't even believe in intuition until I
think I got off all medications and was
like oh you know there are are things
you can pick up on
that are because of your intuition not
and they're real and I I couldn't even
access that until I got off all the
medication but I think watching you be
intuitive helped and I think also
watching you dive into all these quacks
you brought me to mom when I was sick
starting from like grade two mom just
brought me to people that I thought were
quacks after another and it was
naturopath it was people
Chopra hold metal bars to see how you
reacted to sugar and things and I was on
I was so sick that like I wasn't able to
go to a naturopath and have them give me
supplements and have them make any
semblance of difference and the more we
tried the more skeptical I got but you
just brought me to like person after
person after person trying and trying
and trying and trying and so who knows
how much of my ability to
just keep looking and keep looking and
keep looking for answers to whatever
problem pops up is from that who knows
how much of a difference that made
because that I definitely leared that
from
you thank you for telling me that you're
welcome thank you for doing that for me
even though I was not happy about it at
the
time gratitude it's a good thing I think
we could we could end with this one
what's it like living beside someone as
famous as Jordan and how does it affect
you well let's see when Jord was when I
was sick and then he was sick and we'
been apart and then we were finally
together again and we just hadn't been
out to dinner in three years right and
we invited J Julian and Jill to go out
for dinner and we go into this
restaurant and we just sit down and I
can see out of the corner of my eye this
lady running across the restaurant you
know so excited and I thought oh my God
it's starting again and I wasn't ready
right I wasn't ready and he and she was
coming to tell Jordan how much she loved
him you know and and I got up from my
seat and I went in the bathroom and uh
gathered myself
and recognized okay
Tam this is this is life you have a
public life your husband is a public
figure um I did this before and it was
three years ago right I did this before
I can do this
again I just need to take a moment I
just need to take a moment and get my
head wrapped around this and not be
resentful and not be angry that my life
isn't what it used to be and that my
family doesn't have privacy
anymore and that we can be grateful that
that this is a an opportunity and you
know I just had to wrap my head around
it and then I came out and I sat down
and uh so so it's a challenge right it's
a challenge to be married to someone who
who's as well known as he
is uh but I think that he does a great
job because he has space for everyone
even if we're in a rush you know we'll
be in a we'll be late for a plane and
somebody will I'll hear we'll hear Dr
Peterson
and he stops and he shakes their hands
and he asks them what their name is and
then he might say you know I have to go
but he he doesn't ignore anybody and
that's remarkable to watch it's
remarkable to see someone with that much
compassion it's uh it's really something
and I I'm not I'm not surprised that he
has the position that he does have
because because he can be that person
and good for him you know that's what I
think good for him and um when he first
became famous I thought H let's see
what's going to happen to us now because
he's famous and so our marriage isn't
what it was and so if I don't uh if I
don't decide that this is something that
I can be a part of our marriage is over
so I decided I could be a part of it and
you know I started slow I just went with
him I didn't have anything to do with
anything except for making sure he was
fed and and had enough
rest and I did that for quite a long
time and I listened to him and I
listened and listened and listened and
really he'd been a professor I'd never
taken his classes you right I'd never
really spent any time focusing on his
work I had done my own thing but that
year I sat in the audience for I don't
know 200
shows and listened to everything and I
evaluated the quality of his next your
son cuz I was there every day and some
days he was not as good as others and
then I would think what did he do today
was he tired you so I was really paying
attention and trying to make this the
best that I could but the other thing I
do is I listened and I learned all the
things that he was
teaching and that was great so what an
opportunity and I had no idea really
that that is what was going to happen it
just happened that way and then I think
when God came to me it had something to
do with me listening to all of those
lectures and really the Bible was in all
those lectures a little at a time it was
in there and so o I just got goosebumps
you did yeah well I do think that was a
part that was part of why I was able to
access uh my deepest um my deepest
religion was because of that
wow that's crazy
yeah so you never know what's going to
happen in your life so you have to think
about when something like that happens
there's a big shift in our marriage um
are you going to be bitter are you going
to decide that uh it's not your it's
it's not about you so you're not going
to go or or are you going to think
what's important here what's important
here I'm his wife
he he's my
husband uh that that bond has been very
important to us up till now it can
continue to be important if I decide
that I will go along for the adventure
and so I've gone along for the adventure
and it's worked out very well for me as
well as for him but for me as well I
found my place and
uh I'm very grateful so I'm very
grateful why wouldn't I be you know I
mean really it's a it's a beautiful
experience I know that there's
challenges that we're trying to address
and people suffer and we want to be
helpful
so it's
good
wow thank you very much for coming on
nice talking to you thanks for the
invitation Michaela you know really
thank you and thank you for taking on
your life like you have it's it's it's
wonderful for a mother to
see you know it's great okay we'll shut
this off before either of us start
crying
[Music]
okay